- So last week, the presiding judge
in the Derek Chauvin trial,
chastised one of the witnesses,
one of the first responders.
- I will determine when
your answer is done.
- Okay, well...
- Do not argue with the court,
do not argue with counsel.
Answer the questions.
Do not volunteer information
that is not requested.
- Many people reached out and said
that they thought that the
judge was chastising a witness
and was interfering in the process.
Actually, this is much more common
and not very controversial.
A witness has to answer the questions
that are presented to them.
The opposing attorneys have an opportunity
to get the other
information that they want
out of the witness later on.
And that's why in cross examination,
you're allowed to ask leading questions.
But when you're on the witness stand,
the witness should just
answer the questions posed
and not try to interject
additional information.
And that's what the judge thought
that this witness was doing.
So this was not something
that was out of hand.
This is not unusual.
Judges do this all the time.
They really just want the trial to proceed
in an orderly fashion,
and for all the attorneys
to be able to ask all the
questions that they need to,
to get the facts out that they need.
So stay tuned for more
coverage of the Chauvin trial.
And I'll see you in court.